POINTS.
DEROZAN.
>> ALL HE NEEDS IS A BUCKET.
BY ANY MEANS NECESSARY.
ALL THEY NEED IS A BUCKET FOR
LeBRON TO GO 5-0 IN THIS FORMAT.
>> CURRY THREE!
HE'S NOW HAD A STRING OF MISSES.
>> HE BETTER BE CAREFUL.
>> THERE YOU GO!
NEXT BUCKET WINS!
>> THIS IS IT WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
THIS IS WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT!
LOOK AT LeBRON CALLING FOR IT,
REG.
>> HE IS FROM AKRON.
>> LET'S DO IT IN CLEVELAND!
CLEVELAND!
>> GOT IT!
THAT'S THE WINNER!
CLEVELAND!
THIS IS FOR YOU!
>> GAME-WINNING SHOT BY LeBRON
JAMES!
>> WOW.
WHAT A FORUM.
PEOPLE AT HOME, YOU
APPRECIATE --
>> WHAT A GAME!
>> THAT WAS AN UNBELIEVABLE GAME
AND FINISH.
>> THEY'RE LUCKY THE TABLE IN
FRONT OF ME, REJ.
>> LeBRON JAMES WAS 2 OF 11 ON
THREES IN THIS ONE.
>> LOOK AT THEM, MAN.
THAT GOT TO FEEL GOOD.
THAT HAS TO FEEL GOOD.
>> AND CURRY GOING NOT ONLY FOR
A RECORD, AN ALL TIME LEADING
SCORERS IN THIS ALL-STAR GAME
MISSED HIS LAST SIX SHOTS.
AND THIS IS LeBRON MOMENTS AGO
WITH THE TWO DEFENDED BY LAVINE
AND EMBIID.
>> WELL, HE BUILT THESE!
>> IT'S ONLY FITTING THAT THE
KING WOULD COME HOME TO HIS
CASTLE --
>> YES, SIR.
>> -- AND SAY GAME.
NIGHT, NIGHT.
>>